now our dw investigative team has been
working with the china science
investigation that's a european
journalistic research project which is
led by the dutch platform follow the
money and a german non-profit newsroom
corrective
for several months 11 investigative
desks in seven countries have been
probing the nature of collaborations
between chinese and european scientists
now the team reveals that a lot of the
joint research has direct links to the
chinese military
this is a promotional video for one of
china's top universities
[Music]
the videos for the national university
of defense technology or nudt
the place that's deeply integrated with
the chinese military
it's all part of what's called military
civil fusion
as practiced by china's ruling communist
party
military civil fusion or mcf is
enormously important because it
essentially inserts the military into
all aspects of the economy
and vice versa okay so why are we
talking about this well the nudt and
other chinese universities like it have
been getting help in their mission
from right here in europe
dw and its partners in the china science
investigation have been investigating
links between these institutions and
european universities
and we've discovered a huge array of
connections
including almost 3 000 scientific
publications co-authored by both sides
someone highly sensitive subject
german researchers have worked on more
than 230 papers with the nudt
so this is a big trove of papers we
looked at a lot of them and a lot of
them seem quite innocuous but we also
found some papers that might have a dual
use application so that means they could
be used for civilian but also for
military purposes one quite interesting
example is a study that looks at how you
can track groups of people and china of
course is a surveillance state that
might have an interest in tracking for
example a certain ethnic group like the
uyghurs so you can see this is an
interesting example that could have
civilian but also more nefarious
military applications
research on dual use technologies is
meant to be carefully regulated so we
talk to the head of one major funding
body
[Music]
our team took a closer look at dozens of
individual scientists who came from
china to germany to work on advanced
projects
we're not identifying them
[Music]
scientist a is a particle physicist she
spent two years at a nuclear physics
institute in italy
and a further three at universities in
hamburg and mainz in germany
now she's back in china at the china
academy of engineering physics
as the ca ep's website vividly shows
it's china's research facility dedicated
to nuclear weapons
scientist b is a chemist who spent three
years at advanced research institutes in
berlin
before moving for a further year to
liverpool in the uk
now he's a member of the central
military commission led by president xi
jinping
that's china's highest defense body
[Music]
scientist c is an expert in hypersonic
flight who conducted doctoral research
at munich's technical university he now
leads multiple research projects funded
by china's central military commission
including two described as important
national defense projects
several of the scientists we looked at
were in germany thanks to the
government-backed humboldt foundation
its secretary general told us what he's
trying to achieve
we need to build trust
if an autocratic regime goes wild that
cannot be prevented but what we can do
is we can push
the limit where
competition
turns toward physical aggression further
and further away and this i think is
what we achieve by building trust in
this global network of the humboldt
foundation
and yet as our investigation shows
questionable research projects have been
happening
so we asked the junior minister
responsible
why the government isn't preventing this
he pointed to germany's constitution
ourselves
central australia now there's no
evidence at this point that laws have
been broken
but both the european union and germany
have declared china to be a systemic
rival
an authoritarian state that's pushing
for a very different kind of world
china expert dd kirsten tatlow says
doing the kind of sensitive scientific
research with china that we've uncovered
is deeply complacent there's a saying
don't bite the hand that feeds you and i
would actually turn it around and say
don't feed the hand that bites you
the national university of defense
technology is clear what it's trying to
achieve
the question is do european universities
really want to help
[Music]
and i'm joined now by sandra peterson
who's head of dw's investigative team
sandra welcome
um if i can start by picking up on the
last line of the report that we just
heard do european universities really
want to help well you see anya it's not
like european scholars are actively
collaborating with their chinese
colleagues to help china build the
world's most modern army i would say
it's rather a mixture of complacency
naivety perhaps at times even
ignorance um as one security source here
in germany has told us you know
scientists are living in their very own
bubble they think about advancing
research in science and that's where it
stops and um
especially if you look at basic research
i mean that's conducted without maybe at
the beginning a clear aim in mind it's
like blue sky research
and of course that could perhaps turn
later into a military use let's take a
researcher who is looking into
algorithms to coordinate objects that at
some point of course could also be used
to coordinate lethal drone swarms and
that is the gray zone we have been
addressing with a china science
investigation fascinating so yeah let's
talk about the china science
investigation it's a research project of
30 journalists in seven countries how
did it work
lots and lots and lots of cups of coffee
hours of digging and reading and writing
and receiving encrypted messages
many virtual meetings via secure lines
obviously because we were 30 in seven
countries so there's always a risk that
something spills and now a little bit
about the methodology and we had an
original data set of roughly three
thousand uh three hundred 000 to be
specific papers
of at least one chinese scientist and
one european scientist of course that's
massive so we needed to narrow that down
which we did so we looked at only those
chinese scientists being affiliated with
defense universities or institutes
affiliated to the people's liberation
army still too much nearly three
thousand so that we narrowed further
down
to those papers where we could find a
clear line to the national university of
defense technology that's the prime
academy of the people's liberation army
and i'm afraid to say here in germany
alone we found more than 230 which we
looked into is that right now you also
looked at individual scientists from
china didn't you can can you tell us a
little bit about your findings yeah we
have been searching the met massively
also extensively in china and we were
looking for chinese scientists from
strategically important areas like
artificial intelligence physics
chemistry quantum science who had spent
at least three years in germany in the
past decade and who were then brought
back to china by the so-called 1000
talent program that is
the best known government grant program
in china and we found 80 and analyzed 26
of these 80 in particular
and quite strikingly we found 12 of
those had received a fellowship by
germany's humboldt foundation which is
government funded after all
and
while we were conducting the research
two of them
obviously noticing something
changed their cvs that we could see
online and taking off all military
references and i find that quite telling
fascinating stuff sandra peterson head
of dw's investigative team thanks so
much
you